vaccines cue the controversy so to be
clear you believe that your son's autism
is linked to the vaccine today you don't
vaccinate we could have a measles
outbreak and it could become an epidemic
this little beautiful baby and you pump
I mean it looks just like it Smith
foreverspin a safe vaccine never will do
as autism and they save millions every
year and I'm not anti vaccine my much
safe vaccine listening to the media you
can really lose your mind to try to
figure out what the real deal about
vaccines is because there's so many
contradictory points you hear people
screaming all these things you don't
know what to believe and I empathize
with the person who doesn't have a great
medical education to understand what's
true and what's not
we're venturing out in New York City and
we're gonna ask people what they think
or what they believe or what they know
about vaccines to put it simply a
vaccine is the introduction of a virus
or part of a virus that allows your body
to see it to get used to it to build up
its defense and be protected if the real
thing does come along what do you think
about vaccinations I don't I think there
were like experiments and they put the
the virus in us so did your doctor try
and like push you or convince you to do
them yeah like always they always do
that what why do you think they do that
they get paid for this [ __ ] look thank
you so much appreciate it
vaccines are not a blockbuster hit for
doctors or pharmaceutical companies most
of the money that's dedicated to this
research goes to universities it's as
heart-wrenching as it gets autism and
children well the vast majority of
medical experts insist that vaccines are
generally safe you're going to stand on
the stage and say that vaccines and
autism are unrelated it is the most
bogus I've seen the correlations between
multiple vaccines at a very young age
and autism and other problems that
people have people think autism or
whatever is a risk right yeah
okay I tell you like a little history
about how it's really interesting so
1998 this guy he was a doctor at the
time his name is dr. wake here he did
this study on twelve kids not a thousand
kids not a million kids 12 found that
there was an increased risk of getting
autism if they got vaccine this specific
vaccine MMR vaccine measles mumps and
rubella he was paid five hundred
thousand dollars to try and create this
link because of a law company that
wanted to make lawsuits right and this
is only twelve kids he tested so not
like thousands or hundreds out and he
found that there was an increased risk
and it was published they took away his
medical license there was a really big
deal about I cannot say this more
clearly there has been no association
between autism and vaccination zero none
if you had to convince someone that told
you that despite like the best research
that you've seen that there's no link to
autism that they still believe that
there's a correlation somehow I would
suggest to them that having a child with
autism is a lot better than having a
dead child you know what I mean
what I do empathize with you and
understand is that the government
telling people they have to get vaccines
right if you don't do it they're not to
be registered in school that's a great
thing to talk about because in one sense
you want to have control over your body
and what treatments you partake in and
what illnesses you have that's your
right to choose and all of that but on
the other hand if you don't get
immunized you can harm other people and
the reason why you put people at risk is
because not every child can get the
vaccine not every child can be immunized
some have a genetic deficiency in in
their immune system where vaccines don't
work on them in French we have a
a coach of pro boxing but now i've heard
recently in france it's changing a
little bit and we're thinking about
making it along the international
community stands firmly with the US on
this one they believe every child should
be vaccinated and in fact there's such a
shortage of back seats throughout the
world UNICEF says that about one child
dies every 20 seconds from a disease
preventable by vaccine i heard today and
i hear a lot of times for my patients
that they worry that their kids are
getting too many vaccines all at once or
they're getting too many boosters in the
first two years of life and look the
important things to remember and what I
really want to reassure you is that that
schedule is there for a reason it's not
based on a personal whim it's not based
on one person's expert opinion it's
based on data quality studies that prove
this is the best way to deliver those
vaccines I tell this over and over again
to my patients especially when I'm
giving them a flu shot that they can't
get the flu from the flu shot
the reason why people start thinking
that is because the season of when we
give the flu shot is the most common
time of year that people generally get
colds and other viruses just because two
things happen generally at the same time
doesn't mean one of those things caused
the other to happen for those that were
talking about chemicals being found in
our vaccines it's true there are small
minut quantities of chemicals like for
example aluminum that stabilize the
vaccine or help prevent bacterial fungal
growth but the amount of aluminum that's
found in a vaccine is less than the
amount you find in baby formula or
breast milk think about that just
with everything else in life vaccines do
carry some risks however most these
risks are fairly minor redness or
swelling of the injection site a mild
fever
nothing serious there are more serious
complications like anaphylaxis which is
a life-threatening allergic reaction but
it happens less than one in a million
cases and can be fully reversible by a
healthcare professional as a doctor my
job is to always weigh the benefits
versus the risk when doing anything
you're always forced to make decisions
and a lot of the time you have to make
decisions with incomplete information
but your job is to find the best
incomplete information and use that to
make a decision in this case for
vaccines we may learn something new
about vaccines in the coming years we
may learn that they weren't as good as
we thought or there's some other adverse
effects that we haven't thought of but
right now the information that's
available to you the quality information
shows that vaccines are good they have
higher benefit than risk and they
protect us so there's no doubt vaccinate
yourself and your kids hey guys thanks
for watching if you haven't already hit
that subscribe button now to get new
videos every week